All right, greetings everyone. It's May
5th, 26. We're in the first discussion
on chapter 2. We will be having two
weeks on this chapter and continue at
that pace for now. Uh we'll begin with
any section or quote or figure or
question somebody wants to go to.
Otherwise, um I will provide some quick
updates now on the KOD. So there's the
questions table where you can add
questions and review other answers.
There are the figures which we're doing
our best Fraser and Andrew and I to make
sure that all the figures are added for
the chapter's upcoming discussion.
Um and also Andrew has prepared some
slides that we'll be building out during
the time.
Then on the equations page
also through through heroic efforts um
Andrew and Frasier have added in the
latte for the equations and you can see
some cool stuff with the KOD AI. So like
plain language explanations of the math
based upon the latte underlying the
equations. So as we go through different
equations, we'll look at this kind of
stuff too.
So we will jump into chapter 2. Is there
an entry point that anybody wants to
just begin with or a quote or a section
that they want to start with?
Otherwise, let's talk about the outline
overall.
All right. Well, let's talk about the
outline overall and what chapter 2 is
doing in the book.
Um, building on the kind of brain in a
box thought experiment from chapter and
and also just note Frasier has added
some in in progress learning materials
and kind of ways to to run through this.
Um, but we'll look at the figure 2.1.
um bu building on the brain in a box
thought experiment of chapter 1. We're
thinking of this situation where we get
sensory observations, we get data
incoming and we're using it to make some
kind of inference about external states.
And what this book is going to do over
the coming few chapters is in a very
like micro step by micro step start with
a single state and single observation.
So that could be like there's a
temperature in the room and we're going
to get a thermometer measurements.
And that setting of a single state,
single observation is kind of like the
minimal crucible archetypal
observational cognitive situation.
And that is going to be used in 21 and 2
to talk about a few
knobs or degrees of freedom within that
situation of just single state, single
observation. for example, using that as
an opportunity to talk about how the
generative model and the generative
process make the kind of integrated
modeling framework which also introduces
the notation and some of the style that
Nam Jooshi is going to use throughout
the textbook. Then in terms of
modeling degrees of freedom like
different variance and cousins of models
2 talks about linear or nonlinear
generating functions. So essentially
whether a linear regression is being
used to generate the relationship
between hidden states or latent states
and observations
or whether there's some nonlinear
generating function which could be like
a quadratic or a square root type
>> then also in 22 there
>> is discussion of deterministic and
stochastic generative models. So one
could imagine that a deterministic
generative model is just going to be
like a rule-based system kind of going
if then whereas a stochastic or
probabilistic generative model is going
to open the doorway to statistics
essentially.
That's all in 21 and 22.
is going to extend that single
observation
into a multiple sampling situation. And
as we were sort of discussing a little
bit right before we started, what's
really interesting and exciting is how
these algorithms can work in a real time
or online or streaming setting, which is
to say like observation by observation,
making updates at every single
observational cycle rather than, for
example, doing batch-based training. And
there's a lot of algorithms that work
with both or just with batch-based.
And what's cool to think about is going
into that observation by observation
setting because if you think about how
you want an adaptive robot or um a model
of a biological system to be, it's not
like the entity or the agent's going to
get 10 observations, then process the
last 10.
2.4 four goes into some visualizations
of the generative model again to help us
get a handle on what's happening in 2 1
22 23. Then in 25 there are some more
analytic discussions
and probabilistic or gradient descent
oriented discussions around ways to fit
the model and essentially where you um
update and how you choose to update. And
for now it's just being introduced
uh structurally and then we could talk
about like what are their computational
complexity or resource requirements
later on or situationally. So
any
general thoughts or or um questions or
like a quote or a section of chapter 2
that people want to go to
Fraser and then anyone else. Just really
quickly, I wanted to uh mention, I did
put this in the chat, that chapter 2 is
maybe somewhat mercifully. Uh it doesn't
really introduce a lot of new concepts.
It's more about look, we've we know the
lay of the land from chapter one. We've
had a lot of stuff introduced. Now,
let's try and implement that. So, it's
very much about implementation this
chapter. Although there is a lot of new
detail, there's not really a lot of new
uh overarching concepts here. So,
Anyone
else? Just what? Yeah, Andrew and then
anyone else?
>> Sure. Yeah, just my my impression of
this chapter overall. I mean, there's
not much that's new with reference to
what Frasier said as far as like, you
know, we have a a generative process. We
have a generative model which align with
the notions of having an environment and
having an agent. Um but then from there
of course for those aren't who aren't
familiar with you know say state say
statistics or or what is a linear you
know deterministic function or something
like that of course from from that
perspective we're given a lot of
material all at one time. Um but so one
thing that this chapter does is that it
kind of works it tries to use simpler u
models such as just deterministic linear
functions. um y equals beta 0 plus beta
1x is a very standard sort of um you
know you could do you could do linear
regression with that. You could find it
at any point you could find a slope or
something like that. Um and the
intercept and it just follows that kind
of form. But then from there, more
importantly for longevity throughout the
rest of the textbook is that we're going
to start seeing once we do have things
like noisy processes and we start
looking at things like including priors
so that um we can kind of kind of
stabilize uh inference so to speak and
actually incorporate uncertainty into
the computations. we suddenly start
seeing the value of doing something like
using a basian framework and then from
there even starting with like looking at
entire analytic one-step uh solutions to
like uh maximum likelihood estimation
and maximum posterior uh estimation or
inference um instead using gradient
descent and that gives us our first kind
of taste of variational methods. So all
these things basian frameworks
variational inference uh questions of
belief and uncertainty will be you know
a kind of a core primary theme not just
of this textbook but just active
inference and in general. So I just
wanted to say all that.
Yes.
Okay.
Going through the uh sections then to
the questions that are in the table and
in the chat. So 21 introduces the
modeling framework and there's the four
steps there. Define the experimental
setting, define the generative process,
define the generative model and then run
and iterate on the simulation. So that
should kind of remind you of chapter 6
from the 2022 textbook in terms of those
first three stages part of the recipe
for defining essentially cognitive
model. And then here is including in
step four the runtime which is going
from the fast time scale of inference or
perception into the action setting into
the learning or the slower updating.
Yes. And in aa
we have that um
is just any little typos or things like
that like figure 2.2 to there's no red
line, but it's it's the gray line.
Um
the red line is there.
>> It's just small. Okay.
>> Yeah. I think in the print book it's not
there but doesn't really matter.
>> Yeah.
>> 2.1.1
is about defining the experiment in
terms of a state space. This is really
the mapping process itself of
abstracting
situational features into
noted state spaces and then implementing
them like what shape is the variable
going to be on the computer. So that's
where it gets like very clear and
practical and disambiguates a lot. And
um the state space is going to be
consider like the state space are all
the variables that are going to be
stored in the computer for the
simulations unfolding.
Anything you have saved time step to
time step is in the state space.
Anything that's not is not part of your
model within those variables. Some of
them for a given perspective like the
agent's perspective are going to be
observed or unobserved.
So even just the case of temperature in
the room, you can think about there's
the actual temperature in the room which
is part of the generative process. Then
there's the observation of the
thermometer reading and then there's the
agent's belief about temperature which
is part of the generative model as well.
So even just in that sort of three state
setting and then the fourth um node in
the particular partition is like the
action but for now just focusing on the
perception
2.12
goes into the generative process. So
let's look at
equation 2.1.
So triangle over the equation is defined
as means defined as.
So and and we can add as we we had many
um great times doing in the previous
textbook like handwritten natural
language readings using the active
inference ontology
or check out the um AI written and
curate them. if if you see um
improvements to make. So if you want to
see like a natural language
representation
um but big picture the generative
process
is defining how observations why are
generated
including sort of key causal underlying
variables
and a noise term. And that's going to be
a very common way to just model stuff
that essentially makes it amendable to
doing statistics. It's like the
thermometer reading has some signal
corresponding to some actual relation
between the thermometer reading and
temperature and then there's a noise
term which is what can get fit to the
variance component of the um parametric
distribution.
We see that similarly
in um in this
uh in 2.
This is basically like y = mx + b. It's
just like linear equation. There's some
intercept. This is the b.
Then there's MX,
which is like the coefficient,
which is the number before the x.
And I'll bring up the um figure just so
we can connect this to the linear
regression. But the linear regression
has an intercept which corresponds to
when x is zero,
then this term is going to be zero and
you're just left with the intercept and
a noise term. And then as x becomes non
zero, you step away from the zero line
and the overall trend line or the signal
is going to change. And distributional
fitting whether through the one-step
analytic or later the variational
methods is basically like you're playing
with an etch sketch and you can move
this Gaussian distribution up or down.
You can shift it and you can make it
wider or you can make it tighter. And
everything in this chapter is going to
be first about in the single observation
setting and then in the
multi-observation setting. How should
you update your mean centered belief and
your variance estimator on this Gaussian
as you get observations coming in?
Frasier then anyone else?
Yeah, just real quick for anyone who's
like uncertain or has no idea why we're
doing this linear equation where beta 0
plus beta 1 * x. This is a very he says
in the in the text we're going to assume
that our observations are generated in a
particular way from the underlying
states. So we saw in chapter one we've
got a state space we've got dynamics on
that space and we have observations
arising from it. The model that we're
assuming is that the observations are
given as a linear combination of the
underlying states. So that literally
means the state multiplied by some
number beta 1 plus some other number
beta 0. This is an assumption. We could
be we could very well be wrong, but this
is the modeling assumption that we're
bringing to bear on the situation
initially precisely because it's a very
very simple assumption. So that's that's
where it comes from for those who are
unsure.
>> I see. I and I also wanted to quickly
address um question asked in the in the
chat. So theta uh the question was theta
is a parameter in that uh equation. Can
you explain what that is in your
thermometer example? Um so what we could
say uh first is that uh so based on this
figure here um we see all of the dots
those are the actual outcomes. Those are
the observations that the agent receives
but actually so it's the trend line
itself that itself is is based on this
kind of model. It's like well this is
kind of what the the values the outcomes
we expect sort of should be. And then
the reason why all of those dots are not
perfectly on that line is due to noise
uh being involved in the process. And
then um as far as um uh a parameter and
how that goes uh just as Frasier
mentioned we have the beta 0 as the
intercept just kind of like where kind
of your starting point and then beta 1
being your your m your slope um or
excuse me no no sorry that that's a yeah
that is your slope then um the slope and
the intercept become parameters for the
model. they they they say oh not only is
X related to Y but it's related to Y in
this particular way and that's what
leads to that slant in the line and so
on. So um with respect to the the
thermometer example I'm not sure how we
want to say that but it would be some
kind of parameter some kind of uh
characteristic or otherwise of the the
the
generating process that produces those
observations for the thermometer. There
would be something about the you know
the environment um that has some kind of
particular shape to it if you if you
like and that and that shaping is shaped
by the parameters.
Yeah. Great. Like the observation
thermometer could be the millimeters of
mercury because when it's digital
sometimes it feels like it's already in
the format that you want but especially
when you think about the physicality of
of measuring you're measuring something
that's often like in a different domain
than the underlying reference. Okay. So
that was 2 two.
In 2.3
there's the introduction of a sort of
large
bracketed
way to define the generative process.
And so we're going to see a ton of
sometimes quite different looking
sometimes quite similar looking um
enumerations of state spaces.
So here we have y the observation
generation
plus noise. So signal and noise
generating an observation
here that generative
um process
is being it's being clarified here in a
way that that may seem almost a little
bit like redundant but it's going to
give us another articulation. So if you
were designing like a software package
or something this is really important.
It's going to give us a little bit of an
articulation to say we're talking we
when we say xar and theta like
parameters of a generating function here
we're saying that those are going to be
a linear regression intercept and slope.
But all we're going to have to do to
make this into a quadratic is beta 2 x^2
or that could be some other kind of
function and all you have to do is slot
out that part rather than rewrite the
first line. Gaussian noise. This is just
defining. So just like the second line
was defining this first term in better
detail here, omega on y is being defined
as a parameter um parameterized
distribution. That's n meaning normal or
Gaussian distribution with a mu mean at
zero and a sigma squared variance
standard deviation. So basically just
commonly n and then the two then the
mean and the variance of the
distribution
and then also um theta is being
described as the set of parameters for
the generating function. So this is just
like here it's kind of repetitively
describing
essentially the signal and noise
components of the generating function
that is going to be extended.
This is a good place though to get
familiar with what these variables are
going to mean and how how they're going
to um come into play.
Um there is a another way to describe
this. So in 2.3 right above it says we
elaborate on the structural form of the
generative process.
Um
on the next page for uh on page 24 in
2.4
this is the probabilistic form of the
generative process.
So this has a lot of similarities
but it's going to be in a form that is
more amendable to essentially receiving
it and processing it in a statistics
framework
like having um the sigma squared
be a learnable parameter.
Okay. So that was a generative process
generating function essentially
describing the um from the environment
inbound the process of signal conveyance
and noise generation
like from the rooms temperature to the
thermometer's reading focusing just on
that first inbound etcher.
>> Yeah. I just wanted to quickly note for
those who are maybe confused or unsure
about what the distinction is between
the structural form of the generative
model and the probabilistic structural
form. They are exactly the same thing.
It's just two different ways of
expressing the same idea. The latter
representation where we're talking about
the probabilistic form. This is just
more akin to what we'll see throughout
the book later on. So if you're
thinking, oh, I really need to get this
distinction in my mind, you know,
perfectly down the hat right now. You
don't. Don't worry about that. Um, I
just wanted to make that clear. You
know, it's not it's not they're not two
radically different pictures. They're
kind of two ways of talking about the
same thing. So,
yeah, that that's definitely going to
come up. Um, again, two section 213 goes
into the generative model. Okay. So now
we're going to be focusing on from the
agent's perspective
what is going to be the belief updating
for its model of how the temperature and
the thermometer reading are related. And
in this initial chapter and situation
they're going to be essentially
structurally
declared to be equivalent.
And
one of the advantages of having this
kind of partitioned or articulated
framework for cognitive agents is they
don't have to be the same family of
distribution on either side of the
observation. There can be a given type
of it can be a exponential generating
those observations and those can get
interpreted or something into another
family.
There's also a later um elaboration to
have the agent also choose like which
distribution it should be working with.
But in this initial situation, we're
just going to look at the generative
model that's going to have a already
structurally aligned family. Okay. So
equation 2.6 Six
is a a rewriting of basian uh joint
distributional modeling. Like the the
probability of
hot given a reading of 40 is the
probability of 40 given it being hot
multiplied by how likely a priori it is
to be hot. So this is just like a
decomposition of a joint distribution.
And a joint distribution is just when
there's a comma and we're talking about
a distribution over more than one
variable.
When it's with a comma and it's like it
could be two or it could be three
variables considered jointly that's a
joint distribution.
Vertical line means given or contingent.
So contingent means given a given thing.
So it's like what's the probability of
it being hot given that it's sunny
outside. So that's a restricted subset
of the overall how likely is it to be
hot or how likely is it to be sunny.
Okay. Now in the previous section we
would look at no comma means and
this is the the distribution of x and y
considered jointly like a kind of um
like a like a blanket draped over a
surface two dimensionally.
Yeah. So in in the previous section the
fancy e was the environment for the
generative process. Now in 27 we get
into fancy M which is model for
generative model and here we see a lot
of different um definitions and
arrangements but it's like the belief
about the mean and the variance of the
observation given the latent state is
normally distributed
with regards to that generative um with
those those parameters about the belief
about the mean and the variance
um the state. So this is how do you go
from how likely is a given observation
given the latent state. Second line is
about general beliefs about how likely a
given state is to be in that setting.
Here
this is the generative function also
which has this linear form for x and
theta. Yes, appendix C2 for basic
probability theory and definitely a good
thing to to brush up on and
the SPM textbook and documentation
statistical parametric uh modeling not
not to divert but that book holds up in
a triple helix parametric statistics
nonparametric statistics and basian
statistics and those are like three big
domains of tools at your belt especially
when you're doing the application and it
helps to understand some similarities
and differences and like how you can
still lock on to a measure of central
tendency with a parameterized
distribution of central tendency or a
bootstrap or some nonparametric method
or a basian update. So it's just in
practice they might be differently used.
Theta is usually used to mean like all
of the parameters which are here the
regression parameters that the agent is
trying to figure out.
Again in this situation it's a linear
generating process with a intercept
slope and noise and the agent is going
to be trying to fit
intercept slope and noise.
Okay. Then we get to 214
inferring hidden states. Equation 2.8
is
a rewriting of
uh bases theorem.
How you solve bases theorem is going to
be one of the big topics.
There's a form that can be like the
plugandchug form which is the exact base
which is like when you happen to know
these different values you can just
calculate it directly. However, in many
situations,
it may be intractable or you may not
have direct access and or you may only
be interested in the relative adequacy
of different accounts rather than their
absolute adequacy. And so in that
situation, there are some heristics that
can be applied.
And that is especially what's going to
come up in the variational inference
section.
Um
and it is also discussed a little bit in
um 29
which is where y hat the hat is going to
refer to a clamped variable.
So that's going to mean like we're
talking about one specific spike like
instantiation of a given variable. So
not just generally how do those
variables relate to each other but it's
like this is like what's the probability
of X given that Y in general equals this
specific Y. What's the probability of of
of the heat being you know of it being
hot given that the thermometer said 39.
So that kind of operationalizes the
generic basian theorem into something
that's getting us closer to um
calculated being able to calculate.
Okay. Then we get to
2.4. Oh, so here's the likelihood
example, but let's look at 24. Okay, so
here is summarizing the previous
sections. We have fancy E, the
environment, aka the generative process.
And we have fancy M, the agent, aka
generative model.
Right now, we're still looking at an
agent that is going to get an
observation and make some belief
updating. They're not going to take an
action yet.
So, the agent side is relatively simple.
basically the minimal form where there's
some observation that's just empirical,
it's factual, it's 711 millimeters of
mercury.
Then there's the belief about the
temperature which is mediated by an
observation model or recognition model
or a matrix or essentially just a
mapping between how do you go from an
observation to a belief about latent
state. Mark
Yeah, I I just want to try to articulate
this um
P of Y. Um that's this this
intractability of the model evidence.
It's it's often this been it's evaded me
and I've I've thought long and hard
about it. I'm I'm wondering in a sense
if we're looking at just something that
is almost like a model decision. So in
other words,
given the high dimensionality and all of
that that it it's it's hard to to
account for every possible reason why
you might have an observation, but maybe
the the simpler way for me to wrap my
head around it is that most of those are
irrelevant to what the kinds of
questions I'm asking. Is is that a a
fair way to look at it? So, it's not
that it's like it's just computationally
intractable, which I I don't quite fully
grasp that, but it's like I'm not going
to concern myself with these other
causes given that my experience would
suggest this. My my true my model um uh
is in a sense going to clamp that Y or
at least restrict it to, you know, X
possible dimensions. I shouldn't have
said X. a set number of potential
explanations. Is that am I circling that
>> Andrew? Give a give a thought. Sure.
>> Yeah, sure. I Yeah, I was uh going to
respond directly to that. Uh you know,
there are many different ways we could
say this and like kind of as far as like
um the variational methods and and uh
marginalization and things like that go.
Um, the simplest way of saying it is
like, you know, whenever I'm going to go
to the store and I'm here in Chicago,
like despite the fact that my model
technically has all kinds of information
that have nothing to do with the store
or or or being in Chicago, like I have
some awareness of like what the mapping
terrain is in California, but that
doesn't necessarily need mean I need
that. So, so this kind of loose,
slightly crude example I'm giving is
just to make the point that like by
being able to sort of marginalize or or
kind of isolate out the relationships
between particular factors, you can kind
of use the information that's more so
like kind of at hand. Uh, and then that
allows for overcoming cuz cuz in this
chapter we look at very simple problems
where we actually can do something like
we don't have to marginalize
necessarily. we can just take the entire
like one-step analytic solution and find
like oh yeah this is exactly the
posterior. We didn't have to do any
variational stuff at all. Um but this is
an extremely simple example that we're
seeing in this chapter. We're we're just
seeing the relationship between uh an
observation with with light intensity
and and a state is like how much food is
there. And of course like most of the
problems that that people face and even
animals and life forms face are much
more complex than just the relationship
between one specific number that being
light intensity and another number that
being food source. Although of course
there are many problems we solve on
paper all the time that are that simple
but usually things are much more
complex. I hope that was useful in some
way. I know it's a big idea with a lot
of thoughts behind it and the the
textbook will definitely go further into
this kind of variational stuff as we go.
>> Thank you Terry.
Um on that topic um this has been a
constant uh I mean I've satisfied myself
that I can understand that it's
intractable because like the chances of
getting observation
why if it is an alien spacecraft over
the White House you know you you know
for every possible state of a universe
you're it's going to take you a billion
years to think of all those and if
you're a living agent you can't actually
do it in the times aotted. So, I've kind
of got that. But I I remember Fristston
trying to explain this and he talk again
just like Andrew said, he talks about
marginalizing and I'm not a
mathematician and it seems to be that
you're trying to that you have that that
to get why you have to remove X from a
probability of X and Y do you to get to
the so you kind of know the probability
of X and Y but you have to remove by
some magic thing called marginalization.
And my question is Andrew, what does
marginalizing? He says that she worked
it out in the margins of the book and
you you know but what is the process of
marginalizing to get rid of the X?
Yeah. So, I'll quickly say, and I put I
I tried to summarize this in a kind of
oddly typed comment in the chat, but at
one point I put um so the probability of
X does not equal the probability of Y
does not equal the probability of X
conditioned on Y does not equal the
probability of X, comma Y. So all these
are different terms. Um so if we only
had probability of X, then that means we
have the our prior beliefs about what X
should be. You know, we have some
beliefs about what states are. That
means nothing about observations. That
means that one, we don't know anything
about observations nor how they relate
to X. How they relate to states. And
then conversely, if we have probability
of Y. Similarly, we know that's if we
only look at that, then we're saying
nothing about states because the X is
not in there. It's just probability of
Y. It's only once we start to have some
kind of likelihood mapping like
probability of Y conditioned on X
conditioned on being that vert that
single vertical bar that we actually
have a way of relating X and Y right and
then once we we have that um or or you
could even still treat them separately
but whenever you combine everything
together you could also look at the
joint distribution which is the
probability of X and Y kind of co-
occurring. Um so whenever we we kind of
play around with these and we say like
well what if we have this massive joint
distribution we want to know about all
the relationships between X and Y it's P
uh the probability of X comma Y. So it's
everything altogether. One thing that we
can kind of do is that we can start to
marginalize out certain terms such as
probability of X by itself where we do
certain kinds of things. Apologies, it's
it's kind of skipping ahead, but we'll
do things like summing all overall
values of y in order to to kind of come
up with like a good estimation of like
what should probability of x be things
like that. So, it's kind of in the
plainest most abstract unfortunately
terms possible. It's like we're kind of
just changing these terms around to try
and get it just one component of them
out of this massive xy space. We're
trying to only pull out x. trying to
only pull out y and then we can say well
we pull out the x so now that's our
marginal distribution uh of of x that we
kind of abstract it out and that becomes
yeah it becomes really important because
otherwise usually that probability of x
comma y space is essentially intractable
if we try to compute anything with it
it's just it's massive you have to
update you know every small every small
value then of course once we ex expand
beyond the example in chapter two where
we're just looking at a single X
variable and a single Y variable to
suddenly we have hundreds of X variables
and and hundreds of kinds of
observations that an agent can receive
all at once through sight through sound
through all the rest then then suddenly
we we need something like uh like
marginalization and variational methods
>> would just to show equation or figure
2.24 24. I don't know if we want to move
on or not, but that's a very nice visual
depiction of these ideas.
>> Figure what?
>> Andrew.
>> 2.24.
>> What could I ask Andrew a question or a
feedback or a followup,
>> please? Yeah.
>> Yeah. I I'll be more concise.
>> Would No. Would a way for a stupid
non-mathematician be that
marginalization is clever mathematicians
using different mathematical complicated
ideas to get rid of the x value to come
up with the probability of y. But the
the process of marginalization isn't a
process. It's clever maths like
physicists on a blackboard doing loads
of things to get rid of a value they
don't want, you know, and you'll apply
different processes depending on the the
way the data is presented. It's not one
operation. Would that is that a I know
that that's probably not what it is, but
is that an acceptable way that a
a non-mathematician brain could imagine
the process? I would
>> I would say that's fair, but it's it's I
I would be careful about the nuance
behind the word clever, but I see
exactly what you mean. Um, so so we want
to make sure that when we say clever, we
don't mean like kind of deceptive or
skewing things. Instead we want to but
but it is something you would work out
on the blackboard
>> because what you're doing is that you're
you're ex what you can do is kind of
exploit particular characteristics of
different existing uh mathematical like
elements or objects or otherwise. For
example, things that we'll see commonly
is replacing um particular variables
with a log form because thanks to these
really nice natural properties of
logarithms um it it it simplifies things
uh immensely. It can take an entire like
big uh like product like
multiplicationbased problem and turn it
into a simple sum problem which we see
uh later in this chapter on like
gradient descent and things like that.
Um so so it is using certain kinds of I
guess clever techniques I think is is
fair. I mean it's it took time to
discover those but uh but yeah but
they're always they always come back to
like kind of these natural properties
that we find in the mass. It's nothing
that's forced per se.
>> But we we'll return this many times but
the marginal is literally the margins of
a spreadsheet.
>> What's the probability it's hot given
it's low? You can just it's basically a
flattening on a spreadsheet. That's the
the origins of it and it gets extended
into these more higher dimensional and
probabilistic settings. But just in our
in our last bit of this first um
session, let's just look ahead to what
the coming sections are going to take us
through and then there will be um
Frasier's diligent session later in the
week and we'll return to chapter 2 again
next week by by which time like people
can write more specific questions. But
just looking ahead to the next um pieces
of this chapter. So, we kind of have
scanned where we're going to go in this
chapter. In example 2.1 on page 30 we
see figure 2.5
which is introducing us to a basian
network or a baze graph focused on that
critical inference around given a
clamped variable which is shown in gray
y observation and actual observation and
beliefs about
the process leading to those
observations.
How are you going to update your belief
about the hidden state? So that's the
the the crux of this chapter and
essentially what is going to come. So
that's example 2.1 in this linear
deterministic generative model setting
and that's explored more in the food
particle example which maybe we can use
um interchangeably or or instead of the
the temperatures.
Uh page 32 example 22 goes into linear
probabilistic generative model.
Example 23 on page 33 is going to go
into how much should you relatively
weight the prior confidence essentially
whether the prior should be very precise
like a very assured belief about how
food shapes are distributed it's four
plus or minus.1
or is it a much more
dispersed distribution a prior
about beliefs about food. And you can
even just qualitatively imagine like if
you have very strong beliefs in what you
believe before, the observation is going
to have less impact. If you have more
flexible or flatter beliefs about
before, the observation is going to have
more impact. So that comes up many
times.
Page 34, example 2.4 four goes into a
nonlinear deterministic generative
model. So that's equation two
15.
So now now we see that there's this s
variable which is a quadratic
transformation of x.
So it still plugs into the same top line
with the generative outcomes
being produced by some g sub fancy e and
then it's just instead of being
intercept plus a linear coefficient on x
now we have a linear
coefficient on x^2.
But that is kind of exposing us to this
broader polomial family of generating
functions. So it could just be like the
linear which is actually a polomial of
just highest degree being linear but
then it's like to the third power,
fourth power, fifth power, things like
that.
Um, example 2.5
is going to continue our exhaustive
sweep because it's a nonlinear
probabilistic generative model
equation. Uh, example 2.6
in
um, equations 218 and 219
is going to look at the situation where
the generating function
is linear
yet the generative process has this
nonlinear transformation. So that's kind
of giving a demonstration of where there
in in fact between the temperature and
the thermometer reading there is
a quadratic relationship but the agent
is modeling it as if it's a linear
regression. So that would be like
applying a linear regression analysis to
a data set that actually had a quadratic
curve. And again, there's a higher order
of model selection where you could
explore or feature learning in a more of
a machine learning setting like which
transform linear or quadratic you should
use. But that's just showing us like
yeah in principle and that's what people
suggest can contribute to the generality
and the flexibility of active inference
agents is kind of like
um by knowing
what shape the beliefs about
observations are from the inside out.
A wide variety of external situations
can be handled
without needing to know what every
external situation is. Like because we
have beliefs about color and light
intensity visually,
we have potentially open-ended visual
perception.
Section 2.3 extends into multiple
samples. So that just goes from the
single oneshot update situation which is
again like it is the crux of the game.
That's like the pitch in baseball. But
now we're looking at multiple
observations coming in sequentially.
That's a pretty short section.
Section
2.4 4 asks, "So far we have spent ext
extensive time discussing the prior and
likelihood but have neglected to discuss
the generative model itself or examined
structure. What does the generative
model really encode internally and how
is it able to capture all the
information that the agent knows about
the environment?" So you can think about
the generative model plus the process.
So E and M to be like everything the
modeler knows about the situation and
then the generative model considered
alone is everything that the agent knows
about the situation from its restricted
awareness.
Section 2.5
is going to onboard into hidden state
estimation without base theorem
and walks through that in a more
classical setting.
That is going to introduce
two ways to
update beliefs about latent state spaces
hidden states given an observation which
is the MLE and the map which is two
different strategies that we're going to
go into more detail in about how you can
use um different approaches to make that
inference about a latent uh space.
2.5.2
goes into an iterative solution which is
going to start to tease one of the most
fascinating and advantageous aspects of
this framework which is turning a
tractable or intractable
oneshot calculation problem into an
iterative gradient-based optimization.
and 2.6 is the summary and the
conclusions.
So if we pull back to the figures,
we start with like this minimal crucible
template. Like a pizza is the dough,
the sauce, and the cheese. Just one of
them. And then each of those things
we see that there's actually a few
different options for them. And those
are what the experiments and the
different examples in the chapter are
getting into. It's like saying like,
well, you could have um configuration
111, you could have configuration 112,
you could have one 121 221. And starts
to walk through some of those
articulations.
It's kind of like learning these dance
moves like you could lift up your left
leg but not your right leg or you could
do the left leg and the right arm and
then by seeing like okay it it could be
that way in this minimal case and you
can see which things are kind of welded
together
and among models
what opportunities for difference are
there and then for a given situation
what is the actual inference?
And then that becomes especially
important if we want to do not just a
single observation once but we want to
do a batch of sequential observations or
eventually like a real time or streaming
playbyplay
which is what is
approximating the kind of sensory flow
and the unfolding of action in the
world.
So in last minutes just any section or
or question or thought that we could
note down or what what do people want to
explore more in
the section later in the week or next
week?
>> Yeah, sure.
I'll just note I mean the main idea of
this chapter is we're trying to do
hidden state estimation. We're trying to
do perception. So I get some observation
and I need to account for that in terms
of inference about what I what I think
the environment is like. That's all this
chapter is trying to do. There's then
another story about how I select actions
to change the environment to be what it
to be like what I want it to be. But
we're not looking at that just yet.
We're just we're just passively, if you
imagine the agent, right? We're just
sort of sitting there not doing
anything. Stuff is happening. We're
observing stuff and we're trying to come
up with a hypothesis about what we think
is really going on. That's kind of the
name of the game for this entire
chapter. So, it's only point A of that
loop that we saw in the initial part of
of the chapter.
>> Yeah. And just to pick up on that,
Fraser, um it's about
getting an observation and based on that
observation
trying to infer the hidden cause that
caused that observation to be issued by
the environment.
So, so many fun ways to take it. And um
it's kind of like the characters getting
introduced in the beginning of a of a
novel or something. Um like
action is going to fit into this
setting so seamlessly and fascinatingly.
And this is a path of learning that Num
Jooshi has I'm sure um trial and and
tortured many with to find out what
steps will walk us to the point where
when we say okay now what if we were
going to treat action as another
variable to do inference on and instead
of just doing a totally secondary kind
of control theoretic
add-on to a signal processing framework.
We're actually working in this very
general setting where introducing action
is going to be something that is not
like a
no but or a yes but, but it's going to
be already integrated within the same
notation and ontology that's helping us
understand even these minimal settings.
Terry
Um
I it's a question I'm trying to get this
straight in my head that
um so far in this chapter we're we're
kind of saying that um uh for a given
observation there is a state of the
world right and and that there's a kind
of linear relationship in this model
between the observation and the state of
the world. So, it's almost like but
you're not but we're not really talking
about the agent having predicted a
potential state of the world before
making the observation. We haven't
really got to that stage yet. Am I
>> We We have That's the prior.
>> Yes. But have we talked about a prior?
We've talked about you collect an
observation and then you drop a line
down to X and then that tells you what X
is. We haven't really sort of said
before I make my observation I am making
a prior assumption about the world and
then I'm going to make my observation.
we we seem to be more talking that
there's a a a a single figure that is
the value of X for any given Y rather
than and I know we've spoken to a bit of
a you know Gaussian around those things
but it it feels like the conversation
hasn't been about the agents making a
prior assumption about the world does an
observation and then uh formulate and
and then updates its model based on on
the observation that that's the way it's
come across to me so far. And I'm but
I'm thinking have I missed something
>> check out page 40 and 41 again where
this image comes up and you'll you'll
see that relationship but absolutely it
hasn't been discussed in like a
predictive processing brain ass
scientist anticipatory belief um
experiential prediction like a lot of
these kind of deeper senses but yes
there is still the implicit
um encoding of prior beliefs before the
observation comes in. It's just not
being discussed in a sort of like
enacted psychological sense.
>> Okay, Mark. And then and then any last
comment?
>> I was just thinking that we were looking
at uh the mapping of uh causes to
states. I mean that that seemed very
much uh like more of a likelihood
mapping. Is that right? that the prior
uh is there
sort of interacting with that just like
you have here in this chart. I would say
that am I right in when we spent some
time looking at the generate function um
that's that's more
of the likelihood term is that is that
just to kind of build on what Terry was
asking is that is that a fair assumption
just make sure I'm getting I'm not
conflating these terms
>> you've lost comment then what
>> oh yeah it was just to answer that uh so
so the prior think of that is uh P of X
like prob you know P parenthesis X un
parenthesis so that's P of X likelihood
here is actually P of Y conditioned on X
so Y vertical bar X so they're two
distinct things that kind of get used
together to generate your posterior so
recall that bas bases theorem has
exactly those terms right it has the
prior and it has the likelihood uh and
then we we mentioned model evidence but
that's just p of y Okay. So really it's
just it's the it's the way that we can
kind of use these together to to result
in that final posterior computation. The
posterior being probability of X
conditioned on Y. Right? So it's just
the flip of the likelihood.
>> Cool. Also yes please write your
questions or if you don't for whatever
reason find the page or have access or
anything like that like email them.
We'll put them in the table. um Frasier
and Andrew and I will try to answer and
truly it is a unique and priceless
opportunity to have these fellows
address your written questions about
this book. So as if you were in like a
learning setting where you can get your
actual specific questions answered. So
thank you all for joining. See you
later.